monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président du conseil économique et
social européen
mesdames messieurs les présidents
mesdames messieurs je vous remercie
d'abord vous monsieur le président de
m'avoir invité
au lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle à la veille du second
tour d'élections législatives
un moment où le pays sort d'un grand
débat citoyen de m'avoir invité ici dans
votre assemblée
celle qui permet le dialogue je tenais à
m'exprimer devant vous au début d'un
mandat celui qui m'a été confié par le
peuple français dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile au plan
européen avec une crise de l'euro qui
n'en finit pas et qui peut menacer non
seulement la cohésion entre nos pays
mais aussi le pacte que nous avons noué
au sein même de l'union européen vous
m'invitez aussi avant des décisions
qu'il conviendra de prendre au parlement
ou sommet de l'état dans la négociation
avec les partenaires sociaux pour
assurer l'avenir de notre pays et je
voulais à travers votre invitation au
nord- est le défi que vous aviez lancé
exprimait devant vous les grands choix
qui attend de notre pays
il y a d'ailleurs une certaine logique à
entreprendre cette démarche ici au
palais d'iéna
car votre conseil atteste par l'exemple
que notre nation peut être réunir
rassembler non seulement au delà de ces
différences
que je vois ici devant moi mais à
travers elle vous êtes l'une des
expressions de la vitalité de notre
société
de la variété de ses formes de la
multiplicité des engagements des
sensibilités au conseil économique
social et environnemental s'agrègent
toutes les france qui font la france la
france du travail d'abord qui veut
concilier justice sociale et performance
économique offrant des salariés dont je
sais la grande qualification et en même
temps dont je mesure les attentes et
parfois les inquiétudes la france des
entreprises dont je connais les
performances mais aussi les difficultés
face aux défis de l'économie mondialisée
la france des agriculteurs des
commerçants des artisans des professions
libérales des acteurs de l'économie
sociale et solidaire vous tous devant
moi la france de l'engagement celle du
mouvement associatif du mouvement
familial des bénévoles à cette france là
je veux exprimer aussi ma reconnaissance
ma volonté d'explorer toutes les pistes
qui permettront d' instituer enfin un
véritable statut pour les bénévoles même
si les bénévoles ne demandent rien
d'autre que de servir leur pays et en
même temps peuvent-ils échapper à toute
protection et toute reconnaissance je
suis devant la france des territoires à
travers les conseils économiques sociaux
et environnementaux des régions et je
tiens également à ce que la force de
leurs propositions soient mieux utiliser
mieux organiser la france de toutes les
générations des plus jeunes
à ce qui représente les plus anciens
l'alliance d âge que j'ai revendiqué
tout au long de ces derniers mois
car mon ambition dans ce quinquennat
c'est de faire que dans notre france les
îles les enfants vivront mieux que leurs
parents
faire en sorte que la génération qui
arrive pourra réaliser le rêve de celle
qu'ils se fassent ou en somme le mot la
notion même de progrès retrouvera tout
son sens le conseil économique social et
environnemental jouent déjà par sa
composition par ces travaux je vient
interrompre l'examen d'un rapport je
vous présente mes excuses surtout sur la
jeunesse mais le conseil traduit
l'esprit celui du dialogue et un rôle
irremplaçable celui du rassemblement
ce rôle peut encore se renforcer
d'abord parce que j'en suis sûr le
parlementaire qui sera renouvelée pour
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine aura tout avantage à mieux
articuler ses travaux avec ceux du
conseil je ne suis pas là pour donner la
leçon mais il pourrait y avoir des
saisines plus fréquentes
il pourrait avoir des rapporteurs ceux
de votre assemblée qui puisse être
entendu par les commissions de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
de même le lien entre votre assemblée et
nos concitoyens peut-il être simplifiées
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le président
une loi organique celle du 27 juin 2010
à bien introduit la possibilité d'une
saisine directe mais avec un sens ici
élevé
500000 que ce droit de nouveau et restée
lettre morte
pourquoi ne pas abaisser ce seuil pour
ce qui me concerne j suprême mais pour
ce qui relève de ma propre
responsabilité celle du premier ministre
les membres du gouvernement auront là
aussi toute liberté
quand même si elle peut être
solliciter davantage pour venir
présenter le bilan de leur action devant
votre conseil mais je suis le chef de
l'état et je viens vous dire ma
conception de l'état dans la place qui
est la sienne pour permettre à notre
nation de retrouver confiance
l'état c'est l'instance qui oriente qui
arbitre et qui dans bien des domaines
décide l'état c'est une puissance n'est
pas la seule
protectrice anticipatrice
redistributrice elle garantit l'idée
même du bien commun par delà la
confrontation d égoïsme ou des
corporatismes ou l'exubérance des
attentes parfois irraisonnée l'état
c'est la référence collective
l'incarnation de l'intérêt général même
si l'état ne détient pas par lui-même le
monopole de l'intérêt général car l'état
est au service de la nation
il n'est pas la nation à lui seul l état
ne peut pas prétendre tout faire tout
seul
s'il ignore la multiplicité des organes
qui constituent le corps vivant le corps
social
alors ils se condamnent à l'inefficacité
et parfois même à l'impuissance
l'état doit être respectée à condition
qu'ils respectent les autres partenaires
les collectivités locales
c'est dans cet esprit que j'ai annoncée
et je réaffirme cet engagement ici
devant vous une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation
françois mitterrand avait eu ce bon mot
de rappeler que la france avait eu
besoin de la centralisation pour ce
faire et qu'elle avait
maintenant besoin de la décentralisation
pour ne pas sur des faits et c'est
encore vrai aujourd'hui
mais nous devons faire le clair sur les
différents niveaux d'administration sur
les modes de financement
nous devons donner une plus grande
visibilité à notre organisation
territoriale et confier davantage de
responsabilités à celles et ceux qui
sont au plus près de nos concitoyens
les régions devront au delà de leurs
compétences aujourd'hui reconnu avoir
davantage de moyens pour l'intervention
en matière de transports de formation
professionnelle et je veillerai avec le
premier ministre à ce qu'elles soient
associés à la gestion de la banque
publique d'investissement les
départements et il y a encore quelques
semaines je présidais la destine t la
destinée de l'un d'entre eux doivent
essentiellement ces départements se
tourner auto des politiques de
solidarité et de proximité mais nous
avons aujourd'hui une nouvelle
collectivité qui sont surgit de la
réalité de la vie les métropoles les
agglomérations qui doivent être des
leviers de croissance des territoires à
condition qu'on leur apporte confiance
peuvent être des facteurs de
mobilisation mais ils ne doivent pas
organiser une administration qui se
surajoutent dray à toutes les autres
l'état doit également respecter les
partenaires sociaux car la démocratie
doit avoir à la fois le sens de
l'urgence répondre aux sollicitations
des citoyens mais aussi le sens de la
patience pour agir bien et dans le long
terme l'enjeu il est bien là et c'est un
paradoxe que d'apparence pour répondre à
l'urgence
mieux vaut prendre son temps celui de la
concertation et de la réflexion le temps
de transformer les idées en projets et
les projets en actes ça s'appelle le
dialogue le dialogue n'est pas un
problème
il n'est pas non plus la solution il est
le point de passage il n'est pas un
obstacle sur le chemin des décisions il
permet de les prendre librement de les
assumer pleinement et surtout de les
appliquer efficacement les économies les
plus robustes sont celles qui ont été
capable de tisser cette confiance est
d'organiser ce système de relations
sociales fondées sur la négociation
je me suis engagé devant les français et
donc le dialogue social ne sera pas
réservée à des moments d'exception ou à
la réponse à des manifestations
ça peut être le cas ou à des sommets
convoqué pour la circonstance non le
dialogue peut être un processus constant
et cohérent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai proposé de l'inscrire dans
la pratique celle que mettra en oeuvre
le gouvernement mais aussi dans la
lettre de notre constitution
aucune loin plus exactement aucune
proposition aucun projet de loi
modifiant le statut et les conditions de
vie au travail les salariés et leurs
voix mais également les entreprises ne
devra être établie ni adopter sans une
étroite concertation préalable avec les
organisations qui les représentent
c'est d'ailleurs tout l'esprit de la
grande conférence sociale qui va se
réunir ici
quel plus beau symbole réunissant donc
état et partenaires sociaux ses
conditions d'organisation ont été
précisés par les rencontres que le
premier ministre a mené avec les
partenaires sociaux
un programme de travail a été présenté
un agenda sera discutée sur la base de
grands objectifs que nous avons à
poursuivre les uns les autres
un haut niveau de responsabilités au
premier rang de nos priorités il y à
l'emploi trop de français 4 millions
sont privés d'emploi et combien d'autres
vivent en contrats précaires en temps
partiel très éloigné les formes que nous
souhaitons pour le salarié et pour la
valeur travail qui est une valeur
républicaine l'emploi des jeunes et des
seniors constituera notre responsabilité
la plus immédiate
c'est l'idée du contrat de génération
lutter d'un même mouvement contre le
chômage des jeunes est contre la mise à
l'écart des seniors de l'entreprise nous
devons assurer cette alliance dh cette
transmission des savoirs des expériences
c'est la condition non pas pour faire
baisser le chômage il faudra de la
croissance mais pour permettre la
valorisation de ce que certains
appellent le capital humain et qui n'est
rien d'autre que la force que nous
pouvons mettre à la disposition de
l'économie française celle du travail
d'autres sujets seront abordés et vous y
avez fait vous mêmes références
monsieur le président en souffrance au
travail santé au travail conditions de
travail
égalité professionnelle entre les femmes
et les hommes il y aura également le
thème de la protection sociale les
retraites dans la perspective du
rendez-vous qui a été fixé en 2013 mais
également de la santé sur laquelle nous
aurons aussi à réfléchir dans son mode
d'organisation dans son financement dans
la qualité des prestations dans le droit
pour chacun de pouvoir y accéder
j'attache mais aussi du prix et le
premier ministre sera particulièrement
attentif là dessus à la question de la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
nous savons bien qu'il y a des buts à
sion qui est des mobilités qui lie à des
aléas dans la vie économique et nous ne
sommes pas là pour empêcher les
interdire parfois pour les prévenir
pour les freiner
mais en même temps il y a une mobilité
organisée et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter qu'il y ait des salariés qu'ils
soient écartés de la vie au travail sans
qu'il y ait l'anticipation la
préparation et l'élévation de façon à ce
que d'une mauvaise décision puisse
sortir une mutation utile pour
l'économie et pour le salarié ou autres
sujets de la conférence sociale le
développement de la formation tout au
long de la vie est également le
redressement productif ta grands thèmes
qui est sorti de la campagne
présidentielle et qui a été d'ailleurs
évoqué par beaucoup des candidats qui se
sont présentés
nous sommes conscients qu'il ya eu une
détérioration depuis plusieurs années de
la compétitivité de notre économie et
donc de son industrie la perte nombre
dans perte de nombreux emplois
industriels
la fermeture d'entreprises qui avait
pourtant des conditions de rentabilité
l'abandon de certains territoires donc
le redressement prodige sera aussi au
coeur des débats comment pouvons-nous
les uns et les autres nous efforcer de
renforcer les conditions de notre
croissance
l'objet de la conférence sociale c'est
aussi de préciser ce qui relèvera de la
loi ce qui n'empêche pas la concertation
et ceux qui appartiendra au domaine de
la négociation
et puis aussi ces sujets qui finalement
après une responsabilité partagée voilà
l'état d'esprit
voilà le pacte voilà la jada qui peut
nous rassembler même si il y aura
forcément des différences qui seront
dans le débat clairement la position de
beaucoup
la grande question à laquelle nous
devons répondre c'est quelle modèle
social pour la france de demain
depuis trop longtemps justice sociale et
performance économique ont été opposés
comme s'il fallait choisir entre l'une
et l'autre ma conviction c'est que nous
avons besoin d'un environnement social
qui lui-même permettent de donner une
protection contre les aléas de la vie et
en même temps d'une performance
économique dans la concurrence qui est
maintenant face à nous au sein même de
notre pays et pour parvenir à lier la
performance et la justice nous avons
besoin d'inventer d'inventer de nouveaux
instruments d'inventer de nouveaux modes
de financement d' inventer de nouveaux
modes de relation j'ai placé le thème de
la croissance au coeur des discussions
aussi bien au g8 où je me suis rendu au
lendemain de mon investiture que dans le
débat européen
le monde l'europe la france
nous avons besoin de croissance elle ne
naîtra pas simplement de l'incantation
pas même de communiquer au terme de
réunions européennes au mondial mais
elle doit être notre préoccupation notre
engagement la croissance elle ne naîtra
pas non plus de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires
au moment où les états connaissent un
endettement élevé alors elle peut surgir
d'une volonté commune celle que l'europe
peut affirmer de mettre en place des
instruments nouveaux euro-obligations
instruments financiers
notre imagination peut être grande
nous avons besoin qu'il y ait davantage
d'investissements privés comme publics
de mobiliser une épargne qui aujourd'hui
est mal orienté
de protéger notre système financier y
compris de ses propres dérives et nous
envoyons une illustration en venant de
l'espagne
nous avons besoin que la finance soit au
service de l'économie
parce que sinon fine finalement elle
risquerait d'affaiblir et l'économie et
de mettre en difficulté tous les états
la volonté de croissance
elle n'empêche pas le sérieux budgétaire
nous devrons réduire la dette publique
revenir à l'équilibré de nos finances
publiques d'ici la fin du quinquennat
nous doter des disciplines nécessaires
mais je vais vous faire cette confidence
aussi grande seraient les disciplines
aussi lourde seraient les sanctions s'il
n'y a pas de croissance il n'y aura pas
d' objectif qu'ils pourront être
atteints en termes de réduction des
finances publiques et l inverse si nous
mettons pas de bon ordre
un certain nombre de dérives il n'y aura
pas de retour à la croissance
les deux se tiennent et vont de pair le
redressement de la france
reposera sur cinq grands enjeux dont
votre conseil
c'est finalement saisi lui-même le
premier je les dis c'est la
compétitivité de notre économie un
rapport a été fait ici même et son
constat je le partage nous avons perdu
des parts de marché
notre déficit commercial dépasse 70
milliards d'euros quand les allemands en
dégage 150 milliards oui mais d'excédent
il nous faudra donc faire le choix d'une
réindustrialisation de notre pays ça
passera par une réorientation de notre
politique fiscale en faveur des pme et
des entreprises de taille intermédiaire
mais aussi d'un soutien aux politiques à
l'exportation est également d'une
relocalisation des investissements sur
notre territoire national nous devons et
c'est une évidence permettent que les
grands groupes
pire les pme aussi bien pour l'industrie
que pour les services pour les emmener
sur les marchés internationaux
je crois à l'industrie ce n'est pas une
activité dont nous voyons penser que par
l'évolution des techniques
elle aurait vocation à disparaître
au contraire elle prendra d'autres
formes industrie services et je n'oublie
pas l'agriculture qui est au service
elle d'une grande industrie l'industrie
agroalimentaire j'y reviendrai nous
n'avons besoin de production et c'est
tout le sens de la banque publique
d'investissement elle n'a pas cette
banque publique d'investissement à se
substituer aux banques elles-mêmes jeu
je mets en garde contre cette facilité
car ce serait d'abord obérer les moyens
de cette banque ne parviendrait pas à
répondre à tous les besoins et surtout
se seraient exonérés des banques y ont
vocation elle à financer l'économie mais
cette banque publique d'investissement
elle doit rassembler l'ensemble des
instruments de financement qui existe
déjà pour les pme pour l'innovation ou
pour les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire et en faire un point
d'entrée unique pour les chefs
d'entreprises afin que leur projet de
développement puissent être accompagnés
voit même amplifié
l'état actionnaire engagera de même une
réflexion sur son propre rôle dans
l'économie comprendre ce à quoi ça sert
une entreprise publique
ce qu'elle peut apporter de spécifique
quel doit être son comportement
exemplaire y compris en matière de
rémunération nous mènerons également
toujours dans cet esprit de redressement
c'est un second grand enjeu la
transition énergétique
cette transition énergétique
nous allons en débattre lors de la
conférence de rio +20 votre assemblée là
encore adopté le 22 mai dernier un avis
particulièrement intéressant qui
souligne l'urgence des changements à
conduire nous devons aller vers un
bouquet énergétique bien pu dire
si fier promouvoir un modèle de
consommation plus sobre plus efficaces
plus dures 1 face à la raréfaction des
ressources au renchérissement de leurs
prix nous n'avons pas d'autre choix que
de faire de la transition énergétique
une nouvelle frontière je vois ce que
font les allemands
comment ils ont anticipé parfois en
prenant d'édition que nous pouvons
contester
il n'empêche nous avons à inventer créer
des sources nouvelles d'énergie des
méthodes industrielles dont nous
entreprises ont d'ailleurs souvent un
temps d'avancé pour l'efficacité
énergétique
moi je suggère qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de projets qui puissent y être
identifiés sur ce thème de la transition
énergétique et que nous pourrions
chercher les financements indispensables
au plan national comme au plan européen
pour l'heure de nuire pour leur donner
une traduction même que nous devons
mieux gérer d'accès à l'eau à
l'électricité au gaz biens essentiels à
travers une nouvelle tarification mais
nous devons également prendre conscience
que de nouvelles filières industrielles
génératrice de nombreux emplois peuvent
dans le domaine de l'environnement être
sollicités le troisième enjeu c'est la
formation et c'est l'éducation
et c'est la jeunesse votre assemblée on
débat donc aujourd'hui je ne pourrais
pas inspiré de ces travaux encore mais
je les lirai avec beaucoup d'attention
chacun a bien compris que c'est par la
formation des cadres des salariés des
entrepreneurs que nous pourrons avoir un
avantage compétitif
c'est pourquoi je souhaite au delà de
l'urgence pour assurer la prochaine
rentrée un nouveau pacte entre l'école
et la nation
ce pacte définira les priorités qui sont
devant nous conforter la mission donnée
à l'école primaire où beaucoup se joue
rétablir la formation professionnelle
des enseignants car c'est un métier à
travers des écoles supérieures du
professeur mieux respecter les temps de
l'enfant voir comment nous pouvons
améliorer la formation professionnelle
donner une place et une reconnaissance à
l'apprentissage avec aussi des diplômes
reconnus
je sais pouvoir compter sur la
mobilisation de tous pour cette grande
cause qu'est celle de la jeunesse et
celle de l'éducation car c'est la
promesse de la république c'est ce qui
nous permettra aussi répondre à d'autres
interpellations celle de l'intégration
celle de l'égalité
celle aussi de la réussite de la
promotion de chacun de la conscience
qu'il peut avoir au moins pour ses
enfants
quant à la capacité de la république
d'assurer un destin différent de celui
que nous pouvons connaître avec eux une
dimension celle de la culture parce que
nous devons là encore briser bien des
barrières lever bien des tabous la
l'esthétique lebon n'appartiennent pas à
des classes sociales particulières mais
ont vocation à être diffusée largement
c'est aussi un moyen de permettre à la
jeunesse de prendre confiance en elles
et conscience de sa place dans notre
société
il en est de même pour le sport sport à
l'école sport en dehors de l'école sport
pour les jeunes sport pour toute la
société
parce que le sport porte des valeurs le
respect des règles d'engagement
collectif et là encore permettant à la
jeunesse d'avoir le sens de l'effort
l'habitude de l'endurance le goût de la
performance
ça sera une dimension aussi de l'action
publique et puis il y a
le maintien du service public de
l'éducation sur tout le territoire et
dans les choix difficiles que nous
aurons à faire pour arbitrer entre les
différentes ressources priorité sera
donnée à deux territoires celui des
quartiers les plus difficiles de nos
villes
là où
nous sommes habitués avec trop
d'insolence trop d'indifférence à vivre
différentes les uns les autres sans la
mixité sociale indispensable et avec des
inégalités qui se sont creusés avec le
sentiment de déclassement d'injustice
pour les uns de protection pour les
autres dans les établissements qui sont
considérés comme les meilleurs
eh bien nous devrons affecter les moyens
là où il y a justement le plus de retard
par rapport à ce qui doit être l'enjeu
de l'excellence et dans tous les lycées
de france
il ira une partie des élèves ceux qui
ont fait l'effort d'être les meilleurs
qui pourront aller vers les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
de grande qualité
le quatrième en jeu que nous avons à
relever c'est l'égalité entre les
territoires
les français vivent de plus en plus dans
les villes
c'est d'ailleurs une tendance qui
méritent d'être corrigés autour des
villes plus que dans les villes et avec
un éloignement de plus en plus grande
par rapport aux autres et donc par
rapport à ce qu'est la décision le
commerce la culture est un sentiment
beau pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens
d'être relégué avec les conséquences que
l'on sait
quant à un certain nombre de
comportements et bien nous aurons à
créer davantage de logements
voilà ce qui permettra d'allier la
réponse à un besoin social avec une
nécessité d'activité économique et de
création d'emplois nous ferons et le
premier ministre en sera là encore
charger une politique qui mettra le
logement comme la grande priorité et
avec des moyens de financement qui
devront être trouvés et notamment des
fondée par le second territoire sur
lequel je veux
un moment attirer votre attention c'est
ce qu'on appelle la ruralité bien sur
l'agriculture en est la richesse
principale
je veux une politique agricole projet
qui mobilise les ressources qui assurera
aussi une pérennité pour l'occupation et
le travail du territoire qui permettent
aux agriculteurs d'avoir une visibilité
sur le prix de leurs produits et
également des conditions qui doivent
permettre d'améliorer encore la qualité
ça sera l'enjeu de la politique agricole
commune pas seulement aussi d'une
relation que nous devrons établir entre
la france et les agriculteurs parce que
ce n'est pas une question qui
conviennent que les agriculteurs c'est
la question qui concerne notre
alimentation et notre souveraineté
mais la ruralité c'est aussi des hommes
et des femmes qui ont choisi de vivre ou
de continuer à vivre sur ses territoires
et qui doit pouvoir accéder dans de
bonnes conditions à des réseaux de
communication c'est tout l'enjeu du haut
débit va même du très haut débit est
également d'une offre de santé qui doit
pouvoir être accessible l'égalité
territoriale
c'est aussi donner toute la place aux
outre-mer j'ai été très frappée c'est
ici il ya plusieurs représentants de
l'autre main par la gravité de la
situation notamment de la jeunesse son
autre main du chômage de la difficulté
d'avoir n'a encore des investissements
durables compte tenu de l'extrême
volatilité des règles fiscales ou des
règles administratives ou à chaque fois
les conditions changent
eh bien nous devrons là encore faire que
l'outre-mer soit une chance pour la
république c'en est une variété de nos
territoires biodiversité qualité
environnementale ouverture sur tous les
continents et bien là encore c'est le
défi que nous devons nous lancer à nous
mêmes
sommes nous capables de vivre ensemble
sommes nous capables sur les tous les
territoires de la république d'avoir des
conditions de vie sans doute eu
différentes mais au moins le même mode
de vie la même conception de la vie à
travers également des principes et des
règles dont la laïcité fait partie de la
plus grande de nos qualités
la capacité de vivre ensemble presque un
dernier défi c'est celui de la justice
sociale et de la solidarité entre les
générations
là encore vous avez engagé notre conseil
des réflexions très précieux sur le
vieillissement sur la dépendance que de
fois at-on attendu un certain nombre de
promesses et est même une séance du
conseil économique qui avait été
consacrée à la question de la dépendance
donc là aussi nous aurons à en tirer
toutes les conclusions
mais avec un temps de réflexion qui sera
moins long parce que là encore c'est
notre système de santé qui est
directement concerné c'est la présence
d'une population sur notre territoire et
c'est l'égalité pour beaucoup de sa vie
c'est devenu insupportable pour des
ménages où il y a un parent dans cette
situation c'est devenu une charge
malgré tous les efforts que font les
départements et et à travers notamment
l'allocation personnalisée à l'autonomie
donc l'autonomie des personnes âgées je
dirais aussi des personnes handicapées
c'est un combat et nous le mènerons la
justice sociale c'est également
l'égalité devant la santé et ça sera
tout l'enjeu d'une nouvelle loi
hospitalière qui sera présenté et
également d'une bonne organisation de la
santé sur le territoire avec le souci
que nous devons avoir que les
professions de santé professions
libérales qui doivent le rester puisse
être encore mieux associées au travail
que mène l'ensemble des professionnels
de santé
nous avons besoin de tous
pour assurer l'égalité de tous et la
prévention l'information par rapport aux
risques devons être là aussi largement
renforcée contre les addictions les
drogues l'alcool tabac contre les modes
alimentaires qui conduisent à l'obésité
ou à nouvelle maladie contre les
souffrances psychologiques de l'enfant
des adolescents tout cela ça fait partie
également de ce que nous avons à relever
et qui n'est pas sans lien avec
l'économie
parce que pour avoir une bonne économie
il faut aussi avoir une capacité où nous
pouvons traiter tous les besoins des
générations et enfin il y a le défi du
financement
je vais conclure par là j'aurais pu
commencer car sans le financement le
reste a peu de poids sans doute
faudra-t-il changer des modes de
financement
tous deux relèvent pas d'abord des
finances publiques
il ya une mobilisation des pins il y à
ce que peut faire le système bancaire
lui-même
il y a aussi les ressources qui peuvent
être mobilisés localement mais il est
vrai que nous avons aussi à réfléchir et
à décider car maintenant nous en sommes
là à décider d'une modification de mode
de financement financement de la
protection sociale qui ne peut pas peser
sur le seul travail avec des conclusions
qui peuvent être différentes selon les
uns ou selon les autres mais qui peut
partir du même constat mais moi je
suggère d'appeler des financements
multiples si nous voulons répondre
correctement au défi qui nous est lancé
réforme fiscale là encore c'est une de
nos priorités non pas tant pour
rechercher de nouvelles ressources
ce sera utile mais pour faire que ces
ressources soient prélevés sans qu'il y
ait de conséquence sur l'appareil
productif mais sans qu'il y ait non plus
aggravation des inégalités commencent à
une bête que nous
puissions accorder des largesses
fiscales à celles et ceux qui en ont
déjà reçu beaucoup et là aussi il y à un
patriotisme a appelé franchise ont tous
sensibles à ce qu'ils demandent de
l'effort mais qu'ils commencent par eux
mêmes c'est souvent le meilleur exemple
que l'on peut donner pour convaincre
là encore le patriotisme et d'appeler
chacune et chacun à participer au
travail commun avec une égale
contribution en fonction de ses revenus
ou de son patrimoine
nous aurons aussi à changer notre mode
de tarification de beaucoup de produits
par rapport à l'enjeu de la transition
énergétique par rapport aussi à
l'arbitrage qu'il faut faire entre
producteurs et consommateurs et à une
conception de la concurrence qui a fait
que au nom des consommateurs
on a fini par affaiblir les producteurs
ans il n'y a pas de producteur vous
trouverez dit visuellement après des
consommateurs devront aussi modifier des
arbitrages entre les générations je veux
pas les opposer mais la priorité doit
être donnée à la jeunesse parce que
c'est elle aujourd'hui qui se retrouve
dans la situation la plus difficile y
compris même pour les diplômés y compris
même pour ceux qui ont reçu le plus et
qui peine à trouver l'emploi ou le
statut qui correspond à leurs efforts ou
à leur mérite
alors pensez à ceux qui ont reçu le
moins les cent cinquante mille jeunes
qui ont été écartés du système scolaire
et dont après on s'interrogera pour
savoir où ils sont passés dans la
déscolarisation dans l'exclusion est
finalement là aussi dans l'assistanat
l'assistanat pour des personnes qui je
le rappelle ne peuvent pas bénéficier si
je puis dire du rsa attention à une
jeunesse qui seraient en rupture
donc nous avons un modifier nos
arbitrages par rapport aux générations
voilà vous connaissez nos enjeux notre
méthode celle du gouvernement
vous savez que
c'est le gouvernement qui détermine et
conduit la politique de la nation
ce seront donc premiers ministres
ministres qui viendront régulièrement à
vos travaux
je leur fais la plus grande confiance à
condition qu'il trouve une majorité
au delà de l'élection pour les appuyer
mais je veux leur donner ce conseil
aussi le gouvernement ne réussira que
s'il est capable d'aller au delà de sa
majorité au delà du parlement que s'il
est capable d'emmener une grande partie
de la société vers des objectifs communs
d'havas le respect de toutes les
sensibilités d'avoir l'écoutent à
l'égard des groupes que vous constituez
d'avant aussi la volonté de les associer
et en même temps un moment de prendre la
responsabilité de la décision car nous
avons besoin de décisions
cinq ans c'est bien court il faut pas
perdre de temps mais le début détermine
souvent la fin donc il faut commencer
avec une bonne des votes méthode une
bonne démarche
j'ai besoin monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs de votre
engagement de ce que vous représentez de
votre liberté de votre indépendance de
vos exigences
mais en même temps de votre capacité à
vous organiser comme vous le faites ici
dans une société qui est capable de se
parler
le message que j'ai voulu vous
transmettre en venant ici devant vous
devant ce conseil il est simple ensemble
nous devons redresser la france
nous avons à la réconcilier avec elle
même et nous avons besoin de la
contribution de tous oui j'ai confiance
j'ai confiance dans la société française
dans ses capacités dans sa lucidité dans
sa volonté d'être un grand peuple
qui est capable d'avoir un grand avenir
rien n'est inaccessible à la france
telle qu'elle est même avec ces
handicaps même avec ses difficultés
rien n'est pas inaccessible un peuple
lucide conscient de lui-même est
confiant dans son propre destin
merci au conseil économique social et
environnemental de le comprendre et
surtout de le prouver
merci pour votre invitation merci
monsieur le président
françois hollande le président de la
république est donc venu s'exprimer
devant les membres du conseil économique
social et environnemental à l'invitation
de leur président jean paul delevoye
très bonne journée à tous sur les
chaînes parlementaires
c
j'ai fait des propositions d axe
extrêmement précis je pense que c'est
aux français de décider dans le fond
depuis 2008 les gouvernements n'en tire
aucune conséquence de ce qui se passe il
ya deux moments vous savez où il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
un temps une exigence un rendez vous ces
questions d'info en partenariat avec l'
afp le monde et france info mercredi à
19h30
vous allez voir en préalable une petite
salade de mangue et de gambas tout ça à
l'air bien appétissant voici la première
tablette tactile entièrement conçu et
fabriqué en france une tablette dédiée à
la cuisine
longtemps considéré comme ringard le
made in france fait un